bien vieillir avec aussi peut-être
quelques bons plans là maintenant des
bons plans lecture prunelle allaire
captivé aussi tu mode intéressé à
travers les rangées du tout je parlais
d'un rester jusqu'au bout avec nos coûts
de cette émission
pinault ou à les rejoindre ensemble
tiphaine sypher qui étaient avec nous
pour une sélection de livres paraît-il
totalement magique faut m'expliquer de
quoi s'agit-il
alors pourquoi sont-ils magique parce
qu'elle est bien parce qu'ils ont
quelque chose en plus vous voyez il ya
le lire celui ci s'appelle cendrillon
les de lucia calfapietra aujourd'hui au
seuil
vous connaissez sans rayons vous vous
dites pourquoi offrir cendrillon à ses
enfants
et bien parce que déjà les illustrations
sont magnifiques mais aussi parce qu'il
ya ce carrousel regardez vous le voyez
avec des personnages ce sont des menaces
sont nommés oui il y a plusieurs pièces
dont quatre pièces et plus des
personnages en carton
alors la belle mère voilà qui se
transforme en marraine la marraine de
100 millions évidemment cendrillon ici
vous la reconnaissez
mais oui je peux me poussant la musique
mais là je trouve cette france-là
régaler avec la robe de bal faut pouvoir
aller rencontrer le prince charmant
évidemment alors vous le voyez c'est
très amusant ça plaît aux enfants à
partir de 3 ans jusqu'à huit ans et ce
concept est sympa puisque après le
carrousel ce repli on range le livre
orange les petits personnages ça finit
dans la bibliothèque
c'est idéal ça existe pour boucle d'or
pour le chat botté
voilà c'est une super idée c'est un très
joli cadeau de noël je pense puisqu'il y
a à la fois le livre quand vous racontez
l'histoire
les enfants jouent voilà et puis des
choses à découper je lui dis toujours
oui oui bien sûr parce que il faut
continuer à meubler la maison les
chevaux bas se trouvent les meubles
voilà il faut quand même la meubler
cette maison donc voilà le petit allié
dans cette mesure est une bonne idée
mais non c'est un palais
mais je trouve ça magique mais vous
savez ce qu'il sera encore plus magique
oui c'est que en claquant des doigts
la lumière se baisse et que nous
découvrions une autre belle découverte
je ne sais pas si je sais pas s'ils
prenaient le frais d'accord conseil
prône elle sera d'accord je pensais bien
les ah oui oui on va essayer je me
concentre je me console en me
concentrant de possession baisser la
lumière et innover sur la lumière nous
pourrions nous retrouver dans un grenier
avait pas mal vu un grenier celui de
mona le real ce qu'elle voulait c'est
travailler avec de l'encré magique de
lancre magique pour que son livre est
bien permettent aux enfants de pouvoir
faire apparaître des personnages alors
je sais pas si vous les voyez très très
bien il sut super voilà et ça permet en
fait de rajouter une touche de magie à
cette histoire puisque imaginez que vous
êtes un petit garçon et vous vous lancez
dans l'exploration du grenier de votre
maison
et là soudain et bien le grenier ça ne
vous découvrez des boules de noël
évidemment mais aussi des instruments de
musique oublier les chaussons de danse
de votre maman
des guirlandes vous le voyez ce géant
sain et c'est absolument magique
bon on va rallumer la lumière la nôtre
je vous conseille salir dogon puis ça
plaît aux enfants nous doit partir de 5
ans va dire parce qu'il faut quand même
manipulé la petite lente et c'est très
sympa parce que pour les enfants qui ne
sont pas trop lecteurs qui sont pas
familiers de livres et bien voilà ça
leur permet d'accrocher et puis ça parle
de transmission d'amour entre les grands
parents et les parents cet idéal pour
les fêtes de noël
donc je résume cendrillon il est le
renier up la cendrillon le voici tac les
greniers on dirait peter et sloane mais
toutes ont échoué l'an dernier
alors celui là c'est carrément réalité
augmentée complète ou un smartphone we
productions grosse produits très
rentables elles on débarque
je vous montre quand même le livre c'est
de se fit régner nicolas barum forgues
et c'est aux éditions les fourmis rouges
alors quand vous dites réalité augmentée
vous comprenez quelque chose d'aussi on
vous dira réalité augmentée alors je le
faisais explique ce est sur le papier et
de la technologie
j'aime beaucoup quand vous faites la
maîtresse d'école comme symbole que moi
aller au gym je suis pour les enfants
quand même alors ce sont des
extraterrestres débarquent sur terre
ouais elle arrive de bach on a toute
l'histoire et découvre paris les
restaurants il adore notre planète
alors vous pouvez lire l'histoire comme
ça tranquillement à vos enfants je vous
le conseille d'ailleurs la première fois
histoire qui est une un peu après vous
arrivez avec votre tablette et vous
faites votre tour de magie regardez moi
ça ce sont des bébés beef on sai on voit
on voit apparaissent sur votre page
oui oui j'ai vu un truc qui vole une
libellule c'est ça vous avez vu c'est
pas une chouette effraie ça c'est sûr
parce que c'est beaucoup trop vert et
beaucoup beaucoup trop verts et à la
pour un enfant c'est absolument magique
arrive à essayer mettre sa main de
toucher le diffon et c'est donc possible
évidemment un puisque le bio mais pas là
alors il y en a à chaque page zoom ou
alors celui ci regarde et il tombe
carrément sur la table vous pouvez
essayer de l'attraper on vous n'y
arriverez pas pascal clown ton à les
enfants mais essayer avant vous ouais
c'est un échec
nous excellons j'adore çà coute combien
en sort alors ce n'est pas donné mais en
même temps c'est pas si cher que ça vous
voyez ces 17 90 et le prix d'un beau
livre ou en fonte s'est pas appuyé sur
originalement parce que mais franchement
les enfants aujourd'hui sur la tablette
1 voilà ils sont tous des tablettes on
aime on n'aime pas c'est comme ça c'est
le progrès voyez vous donc on marie la
tablette avec un lecture voilà et le
livre se veut enfin voilà ils paissent
lire tout seul
vous rajoutez la tablette ça fait un
livre magique et j'adore je le remercie
pour cette magie de noël
tiphaine pour cette jeune serveuse
moi non plus je vous ai pas menti je
vous ai promis qu'on allait retrouver
l'équipe de c'est votre auto en direct
avec amélie dans deux directions la
minoterie à dijon on dit oui on dit non
qu'est ce qu'on me dit